bonsoir voici les titres de cette
édition
entrée en vigueur de l'obligation
d'étiquetage des aliments contenant du
soja ou du maïs transgénique
l'avertissement consommateur est valable
pour toute l'europe
l'opération policière internationale
anti pédophile dans 21 pays dont les
états unis plus d'une centaine de
personnes ont été arrêtées charles
millon exclue du groupe parlementaire de
l'udf pour compromission avec
l'extrémisme de droite monsieur charles
millon à notre invité johnny hallyday
dans un pari fou au stade de france en
compagnie de michel drucker nous verrons
comment l'idole des jeunes descendra du
ciel
à compter d'aujourd'hui les
consommateurs que nous sommes pourront
exiger d'être informés précisément sur
la présence ou non dans les produits
alimentaires d'organismes génétiquement
modifiés les ogm c'est une
réglementation européenne mais les
modalités précises de cet étiquetage ne
sont pas encore vraiment défini comment
savoir si ce que mange on était
génétiquement amélioré
voici l'explication avec le reportage de
marie pierre samitier jean louis goût
serre sur les produits les moins chers
attention promotion et toussaint plus
tôt certains ne voient que les
promotions écrite en gros mais ceux qui
refusent les produits modifiés
génétiquement devront aussi regarder les
emballages de très près la nouvelle
réglementation européenne prévoit que
les ogm soient mentionnés or c'est sur
la liste des ingrédients écrit en tout
petit c'est le cas de ces cannellonis
surgelés qui ont un emballage conforme à
la nouvelle législation
difficile de repérer les organismes
transgéniques génétiquement modifiés ce
sera écrit en gros ce serait mieux mais
faudrait pas avoir à chercher je pense
beaucoup refusent par principe tout
aliment modifiés génétiquement
mais nous en avons tous déjà consommé
sans savoir car les ogm sont entrés à
notre insu dans de nombreux aliments
on en trouve dans les produits
américains portés mais aussi dans les
biscuits les barres chocolatées et tous
les produits qui contiennent de la
lécithine de soja
les sit in à base de soja transgénique
venue des états unis
or la lécithine fait partie des additifs
et la réglementation européenne a tout
prévu sur les ingrédients mais n'a
encore rien édictées sur les additifs
même si des analyses prouvent que tel
produit contient un additif issus de
soja par exemple la lécithine et quel
étranger ni qu il n'y a pas obligation
de le noter sur la composition
parce que cet additif ne rentre pas dans
la réglementation actuellement seuls les
produits biologiques ne contiennent
aucun organisme génétiquement modifié
des ogm qui peuvent avoir des
répercussions sur la santé car on les
consomme en certains risques de
développer des allergies ou de résister
à certains antibiotiques
oui mais les méthodes de détection des
organismes génétiquement modifiés ne
sont pas encore homologué par la
commission européenne de bruxelles
cependant à montpellier les chercheurs
du laboratoire de l'inra l'institut
national de la recherche agronomique
établi sur des séries de produits très
divers de consommation courante des
conclusions des analyses assez
surprenante
reportage de rumble bonnan et frédéric
de la rue dans ce laboratoire qui fait
partie des quatre laboratoires français
du réseau européen de détection des
organismes génétiquement modifiés à
l'intérieur de ses cartons des aliments
prélevés dans le commerce par des
inspecteurs de la répression des fraudes
du coup pour ses ingénieurs de l'inra le
travail peut commencer
des recherches pour détecter si par
exemple ses barres chocolatées ont été
ou non fabriqués à partir de maïs ou de
soja génétiquement modifiées pour y
parvenir il faut aller au coeur de la
matière dans l'adn du produit peut-être
si trouve-t-il cacher l'un des 230 gènes
connus sur la planète
toute une collection contenues dans ces
tubes et qui va servir de référence pour
détecter les modifications génétiques
cette collection nous est bien souvent
fournies par l'intermédiaire des
semenciers qui normalement sont tenus de
déposer là la totalité les éléments
contenus dans la construction génie
c'est à dire la peau qualité des
éléments concernant le trajet au moment
de l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
grâce à ce procédé les chercheurs
peuvent retrouver avec certitude la
présence même infime d'un transgene com
ici pour ce maïs seulement voilà tous
les pays ne joue pas la transparence
certains organismes génétiquement
modifiés
mise au point en asie notamment n'ont
pas été répertoriés
impossible donc de repérer s'ils ont
servi à la fabrication d'un aliment
vendus en france
autre difficulté le mode de fabrication
de certains aliments empêche toute
détection
cela dépend de la nature du produit
selon leur degré de transformation si
vous avez des huiles des sucres des
preuves plats cuisinés
qui ont subi tout un tas de
transformation de purification on va
plus être à même de détecter l'adn d'ici
la fin de l'année
les laboratoires publierons une liste de
produits dont l'éventuelle modification
génétique est impossible à prouver mais
dans les rayons des magasins
rien ne sera prévu pour informer les
consommateurs
21 pays ont décidé d'associer leurs
polices pour procéder à l'arrestation
d'une centaine de personnes constituant
un réseau de pédophiles diffusant des
images pornographiques d'enfants sur
internet
l'opération s'est déroulée aussi bien
aux etats-unis dans 22 états qu'en
scandinavie en australie et dans
plusieurs autres pays européens dont la
france
des dizaines de milliers d' images ont
été saisies commentaires agnès vahramian
et philippe visseyrias des cd rom des
disquettes informatiques et des
cassettes vidéos saisies en allemagne
pour arriver jusqu'à ce matériel les
enquêteurs n'ont d'abord une adresse
internet
il leur a donc fallu plusieurs semaines
pour identifier ce qui se cachait
derrière les écrans d'ordinateur deux
hommes ont finalement été interpellé en
allemagne
mais l'opération a touché 21 pays 100
personnes ont été arrêtées
une trentaine aux etats-unis 4 en france
tout à la fois consommateurs et
fournisseurs du réseau selon la police
française pour accéder au réseau
il fallait d'abord fournir de très
nombreuses images temps qu'il fait déjà
avoir un potentiel ou une personnalité
particulière
cent mille images à caractère pédophile
ont été en tout saisi l'an iv a débuté
en angleterre où les autorités affirment
que les enfants photographiés étaient
des proches des membres du réseau
certains n'allait pas deux ans j'ai
beaucoup d'enfants maltraités dans cette
affaire ils trouvent sont les retrouve
maintenant pour leur porter assistance
et protection le plus vite possible
les utilisateurs du réseau ne se
connaissaient pas entre eux et agissez
sans beaucoup se méfier répressive cette
opération internationale se veut donc
aussi dissuasive à bruxelles ce matin
première journée d'un procès de
corruption présumée impliquant
l'industriel serge dassault ainsi que
l'ancien secrétaire général de l'otan le
belge willy claes deux sociétés
d'armement agosta et dassault sont mises
en cause dans le versement de
pots-de-vin de
millions de dollars aux socialistes
belges et cela afin de remporter des
contrats
reportage à bruxelles de nos envoyés
spéciaux olivier caroff emmanuel bec
serge dassault s'est il rendu coupable
de corruption
la réponse définitive et sans appel
viendra de ces quinze magistrats belges
depuis ce matin l'industriel français
comparés de vente e pour une affaire de
commissions occultes lors d'une vente
d'armes à ses côtés sur le banc des
accusés pas moins de dix anciens hauts
responsables du gouvernement belge des
partis socialistes wallons et flamands
et même un ancien secrétaire général de
l'otan willy claes
pour serge dassault arriver bien plus
discrètement palais de justice
les ennuis ont commencé il y a trois ans
lorsqu'un juge d'instruction belge vient
perquisitionné le siège de son groupe
ce magistrat fait partie d'une équipe
d'enquêteurs chargés d'élucider un
meurtre commis en 91 celui d'andré cools
un vice-premier ministre socialiste qui
comptait beaucoup d'ennemis parmi eux
agusta un fabricant d'hélicoptères
italiens dont on retrouve l'argent sur
les comptes en banque de certains
socialistes
c'est en épluchant leurs relevés
bancaires que les enquêteurs découvrent
un autre marché suspect remporté sept
fois par dassault un milliard de francs
pour moderniser les avions de chasse
belge en échange
l'avionneur aurait payé 20 millions de
francs de commissions
parmi les accusés un homme affirme même
avoir été payée en liquide par un cadre
de chez dassault mais aujourd'hui on
n'en était qu'aux préliminaires
et on était sur un banc et donc monsieur
dassault est un autre bout du banc donc
j'ai pas pu remarquer la façon dont il
sait dont il s'est comporté jamais su
qu'ils ont aimé l'ambiance quelle est
l'ambiance entre les adultes b vous êtes
parler une ambiance de gens civilisés
courtois le ton restera t-il le même
pendant les longues semaines que doit
durer ce procès on peut en douter
d'autant que pour serge dassault c'est
avant tout l'image de son entreprise qui
est en jeu dans un monde celui des
fabricants d'armes ou le versement de
commissions occultes et paraît-il
monnaie courante se faire condamner pour
corruption pourrait relever au mieux de
la maladresse au pire de la faute
professionnelle et en matière judiciaire
j'ajoute deux informations la libération
annoncée pour vendredi d'omar raddad
l'information n'est pas confirmée par
ministre de la justice marc haddad avait
été condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
criminelle en 94 pour le meurtre de
madame ghislaine marchal commis en 91
marada toujours nié les faits et puis le
policier de la brigade anti criminelle
de tarbes qui a tué par balles un homme
lundi soir dans cette ville a été mis en
examen aujourd'hui pour homicide
volontaire
le policier a été écroué exclusion de
chars millions et de jean pierre soisson
du groupe udf alliance de l'assemblée
nationale le comité exécutif de ce
groupe présidé par philippe douste-blazy
estimé qu'il ne suivait pas la ligne
politique de l'udf c'est à dire ni
alliance ni connivence ni compromis avec
le front national à 19h vous le voyez le
bureau provisoire de l'alliance qui
rassemble le rpr ni l'udf et démocratie
libérale sur et nice et au siège du rpr
avec françois bayrou françois léotard et
monsieur alain madelin charles million
bonsoir ça vous fait quoi d'être exclu
du groupe parlementaire sdf
tout d'abord je voudrais vous dire que
très franchement j'aurais préféré venir
sur ce plateau
dans d'autres circonstances car je crois
que tous ces petits jeux partisans
ces exclusions c'est ostracisme sont en
train de donner une image de la
politique qui scandalise vos concitoyens
vous avez joué assez petit jeu vaut
aussi pendant un moment vous avez fait
partie des parts non je ne crois pas
avoir joué avec les petits jeux j'ai été
président du groupe udf durant six ans
et on s'occupait du chômage on
s'occupait de la rentrée scolaire on
s'occupe pas du système et des glandes
justement lors sont vos amis qui vous
exclut ça vous fait quoi
je suis attristé j'étais président du
groupe durant six ans j'y compte
beaucoup d'amis dans ce groupe
je suis surtout choqué de la procédure
le parti eut des fc union pour la
démocratie française sa partie donc
démocratique
or là j'ai été exclue comme un malpropre
sans être écoutés sans être entendus et
monsieur tout ce que bunny par le bureau
exécutif ni par les nazis sienne nos
amis politiques et dit que vous êtes en
pleine connivence avec l'extrême droite
avec le front national et ça c'est pas
admissible
vous lui répondez quoi je réponds qu'il
a tort il a quatre de venir voir ce qui
se passait dans la région rhône alpes
il ya un président qui a été élu sur son
programme qui est le programme qui était
présenté par les liste rpr udf
non-inscrits ce programme est mis en
oeuvre sans eau grise il manque quand
même non pas du tout difficilement
culturel c'est difficile qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ce pont culturel dans la
biennale
elle a obtenu 1 million de subventions
la région rhône alpes personne ne l'a
dit un million de subventions
qu'est-ce que ça qui n'a pas été
subventionnés c'est le défilé donc la
biennale elle a été subventionné alors
il y à peu près 90 7 % des décisions que
j'ai soumis aux régionales ont jusqu'à
maintenant été votée c'est ce qu'a
démontré la dernière commission
permanente monsieur monsieur millions
monsieur douste-blazy à tort monsieur
raymond barre à tort monsieur alain
juppé à tort monsieur chirac à tort ils
ont tous tort vous avez raison contre
contre tous dans le j'aime bien qu'il
fasse une analyse politique
est-ce que vous pouvez avoir raison
contre moi je moi je vais faire une
analyse politique
actuellement il y a environ 15 % de
français qui vote soit protestataires
soit extrémistes c'est des gens qui sont
amers déçus qu'ils votent pour une
formation qui par certains aspects à
comportement où il est récupéré
pas du tout ces gens là ils votent c'est
jean-yves up pour les conseillers
régionaux ses conseillers régionaux ils
viennent dans une assemblée ses
conseillers régionaux
il préfère telles personnes à tel autre
il n'y a ni négociation ni record à
partir de ce moment là est ce qu'on ne
va pas répondre à l'attenté de ces gens
là est-ce qu'on va dans notre pays
ostracisé tout lien électorat jeu
répondant je pense que ces gens qui sont
amers déçu révolter eh bien ils doivent
aujourd'hui avoir une réponse des aubes
notre démarche vous n'auriez pas pu la
faire en restant au sein du df c'est à
dire en ayant la même ligne que vos amis
politiques
pourquoi est ce que vous mettez à part
vous créez un monsieur a pris la barre
c'est vous qui avez créé la droite n'en
mettrais la droite je les crée parce que
je pense que aujourd'hui tous les
problèmes qui se passe ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à l'alliance qui était un
accord d'état-major tous les problèmes
que ressentent l'électorat c'est dire
l'éloignement du monde politique de
leurs problèmes sont la conséquence d'un
éparpillement d'une division et d'une
sclérose de la droite
j'ai toujours été favorable à une grande
formation unique de la droite et je suis
décidé à tout mettre en oeuvre pour
faire trois choses 1 pour changer le
comportement politique ça veut dire ça
veut dire quoi qu'on soit modeste qu'on
sache écouter les gens à force de tout
d'avoir que ça n'a rien d'un j'espère
mais la méthode des hommes politiques
écoutent donc en soit honnête
ce sera intéressant pour pas grand sens
noir et que monsieur juppé ce plaisir et
mon garçon polonais non mais je ne suis
pas là pour porter des jugements sur les
personnes je ne suis pas comme les
autres je suis pas là pour juger et ce
pur ostracisé mais se fait là-bas comme
les autres ça veut dire que vous êtes
supérieur que les autres non non je suis
là pour définir une méthode je veux un
premièrement un nouveau comportement
politique mais ce que veut faire un
patin ce moment là le nos électeurs nous
écouterons 2 je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit de droite et qu'on ne soit pas
complexés aux mains des rebelles
on est déjà le moral j'ai des
convictions de droite je crois un
certain nombre de choses telles que la
liberté d'initiatives telles que
l'égalité des chances je crois qu'il ya
des communautés qu'il convient de
renforcer dans une société telle que la
famille l'entreprise la commune le monde
est d'accord elle attendait mais dans ce
cas il faut le faire
lisa ce cas il faut le faire
pratiquement non il faut il faut
répondre aux aspirations des étudiants
vous avez déclaré dans le mensuel lyon
mag que vous ne vouliez pas d'alliance
de la droite avec le front national
où est ce que je suis contre le régime
du parti mesdames intéresse pourtant
dans votre mouvement notamment je pense
à monsieur poniatowski monsieur
griotteray ils sont pour une alliance
avec le front national
moi je m'appelle charmilles ont jusqu'à
maintenant donc je vous dis ma position
qui est clair je suis pour la
constitution d'une grande formation
unique de la droite en france car je
suis sûr qu'à partir de ce moment-là
comme cela se passe en angleterre comme
cela se passe en allemagne comme cela se
passe en espagne
vous aurez une grande formation ouzou
une pluralité d'opinions qui au lieu de
se quereller pour savoir qui est chef de
l'adq
braud qui va être patron de tels
mouvements s'occupera des problèmes des
français
les françaises en marre ils viendraient
qu'on s'occupe de la sécurité dans leur
quartier qu'on s'occupe du site de la
réforme du système online games
humiliant oui et bien d'autres il faut
le faire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pris des décisions au
niveau du conseil régional je me suis
fait élire sur un programme
je me suis engagé vis-à-vis des lecteurs
les électeurs quand je parcourais les
banlieues et les régions de ronald
qu'est ce qu'il me disait il disait les
engagements que vous allez prendre vous
prenez est ce que vous allez les tenir
je leur réponds oui je les tiens un
point c'est tout merci monsieur campagne
électorale en ce moment même à toulon
sept candidats se disputent l'honneur de
siéger à l'assemblée nationale pour
représenter les électeurs de la première
circonscription du var les deux tours de
cette élection sont prévues les 20 et 27
septembre prochains le conseil
constitutionnel avait invalidé
l'élection de la socialiste madame
odette casanova à la suite de la
diffusion d'une séquence dans une
émission de canal plus appelant à faire
barrage à la candidate du front national
l'épousé du maire de toulon madame
sandrine chevalier
reportage à toulon sur cette campagne
particulière michaël darmon et yann
streiff est de 3,3 campagne à toulouse
en un peu plus d'un an
et voilà odette casanova devenu expert
son aménagement de permanences
électorales station des bureaux de vote
et ça c'est le magazine financier le 3
mai dernier elle battait la candidate du
front national avec seulement 33 voix
d'avancé une élection annulée fin
juillet aujourd'hui la gauche plurielle
s'apprête une nouvelle fois affrontées
sandrine le chevalier passer de celle là
parce qu'on trouve que
on avait on avait gagné et qu'on avait
gagné légitimement la preuve c'est que
c'est reconnu par le conseil
constitutionnel qu'on a comme unique une
fête mais nous repartons confiant et
décider gauche plurielle et droite
divisée rien n'a changé à toulaud et le
candidat rpr udf est clair ici d'un jour
nouveau les divisions de la droite mark
bell va tenter de rassembler cette
partie de l'électorat qui veut se
rapprocher de charles millon je pense
que la sensibilité qu'incarnent
aujourd'hui charles millon et qu'une
composante de la droite et de la droite
à toulon et champignons ce que street
mais très clairement le dessus
il soutient le congrès de l'alliance
mais son parcours d'anciens dissidents
ne plaît pas ici à sa famille politique
qui le considère comme un candidat
devant faire ses preuves si demain elle
gagne cette élection législative et sera
d'une manière incontestable leader de la
droite
par contre dans le cas contraire il
faudra certainement qu'ils apprennent ml
c est que la droite apprennent à se
reconstruire la faille un sens c'est
dans les couloirs du congrès n'était que
cendres et le chevalier a reçu ses
premiers soutiens politiques l'épousé du
maire de culoz est toujours persuadé que
le fn est capable ici de séduire
l'électorat de droite
c'est du non certaines comme celle là
mais fera voter socialo communistes
parce que c'est un homme de gauche mais
son électorat j'ai confiance en
l'électorat mais qui aujourd'hui a
conclu premier tour dimanche 20
septembre dans une ville qui devient peu
à peu le laboratoire des problèmes de la
droite face au front national
la proposition de loi sur le pacte civil
de solidarité sera bien présenté au
parlement le 9 octobre prochain après
son adoption en conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui cette proposition vise à
donner un cadre juridique et fiscal aux
couples non mariés
le président de la république monsieur
jacques chirac est arrivé cet après midi
à kiev la capitale de l'ukraine c'est la
première fois qu'un chef de l'état
français se rend dans ce pays dont
l'indépendance remonte à août 91 en
ukraine on craint déjà les retombées de
la crise russe et certains symboles du
passé communiste ne sont pas effacés
reportage véronique saint-aulaye gens
connus dans un square abandonné en plein
coeur de kiev
la statue de lénine et déboulonné
pourtant sept ans après la proclamation
de son indépendance
l'ukraine dont l'économie demeure liée à
plus de 40% à l'économie russe n'a
jamais été aussi fragile sur les
étalages des marchés rien ne manque
mais les acheteurs sont inquiets et font
de plus en plus attention
les secteurs bancaires et craignait
russes ont totalement imbriqués et la
crise financière russe fait chaque jour
plus lourd mais devant la banque
centrale comme pour éviter la panique
les déclarations se veulent rassurantes
la direction de la banque nationale a
pris des mesures ici la monnaie est
stable et les gens en confiance je suis
comme les et rien ne me fait penser
qu'il y aura une dévaluation
dans ce contexte la visite du président
de la république tombe plutôt mal
la france plaide auprès du fmi pour le
maintien d'un soutien financier
indispensable pour éviter la faillite de
l'ukraine mais en contrepartie jacques
chirac dès aujourd'hui réaffirmer la
nécessité absolue de poursuivre les
réformes vers plus de démocratie est une
économie ouverte
l'ukraine rêve de s'associer à l'union
européenne et dans ce domaine aussi
comptent sur le soutien français malgré
toutes ces difficultés
vendredi dernier le ministre des
finances ukrainien après avoir rencontré
le directeur du fmi confiait qu'une
dévaluation en ukraine était plus que
probable
ils n'excluaient même pas qu'elle puisse
intervenir pendant le séjour du
président jacques chirac
les suites des montagnes russes
boursière aujourd'hui à paris la hausse
est peut-être 2,29 % les gains francfort
de 3 7% et aux états unis.l'indice de la
bourse de new york était également à la
hausse à mi séance
à moscou la banque centrale de russie à
l'intention de suspendre des activités
de cinq grandes banques commerciales
et tandis que s'achevait la visite du
président américain bill clinton que le
président alcine affirment être les
réformes serait mené jusqu'au bout le
général alexandre lebed estimé ce matin
que la situation dans son pays et est
pire qu'en 1917 commentaires gérard
griesbeck
une démarche d'automates à voir boris
eltsine aujourd'hui les autres soit
croyait revenu au temps de brejnev sur
la fin la signature des deux accords de
désarmement a été laborieuse
la conférence de presse commune aussi
première gaffe boris eltsine a parlé
d'un prochain sommet de l'otan à
varsovie
ce sommet n'a jamais été programmé et
lorsqu'un journalistes l'interrogent sur
l'avenir de son premier ministre
je dois dire que nous aurons encore
beaucoup d'événements avant d'atteindre
ses résultats comprenne qui pourra
le président américain est effaré devant
un tel charabia les journalistes
préférant rives bill clinton lui a
rappelé que la russie devait poursuivre
son chemin sur la voie des réformes
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour
redresser la situation
cela dépend de vous de ce qui se fera
ici on trouve pas d'étrangers s'il ya un
clair engagement vers les réformes alors
je ferai tout mon possible pour
accélérer un soutien extérieur
le chef du parti communiste guennadi
ziouganov a été reçu par bill clinton
avec d'ailleurs une douzaine de
parlementaires dont le fameux général y
et bed qui n'a pas mâché ses mots
l'armée pourrait se montre agressive at
il dit si l'actuel bras de fer politique
débouché sur une confrontation ouverte
dans la vie quotidienne les russes
apprennent jour après jour de nouvelles
hausses de tarifs depuis les produits
alimentaires jusqu'aux ticket de métro
ce qui fait craindre chez certains
hommes politiques à moscou des réactions
de mécontentement populaire grave
reportage à moscou de notre
correspondant permanent gilles rabin sur
les conséquences de cette crise
économique
en pleine rentrée scolaire pour son
cartable
elle a choisi anastasia
sa copine elle a choisi walt disney
éternelles querelles est-ouest
moi j'ai une poche en plus avec un
velcro en russie la rentrée scolaire
c'est toujours le 1er septembre
et c'est toujours un jour de fête la
journée du savoir mais cette année la
fête est gâchée et pas seulement à cause
de la pluie
c'est trop cher si tu veux tout péché
des coups nous on a gardé des choses de
l'année dernière on a gardé la vieille
habitude soviétique de tout acheter
d'avançon n'a acheté avant la
dévaluation donc cette année pour nous
ça va mais la plupart des autres ont été
pris de court par la dévaluation survenu
en plein mois d'août alors que les
familles russes sont traditionnellement
en vacances pour la plupart à la datcha
à la campagne tout est cher
si vous voulez un minimum de qualité
c'est inaccessible
on a juste regarder les prix en russie
le premier jour d'école on vient
habiller comme pour un dimanche alors
que les moyens viennent juste de rentrer
dans leur classe les ados les plus
grands sont déjà en cours
la crise économique ils connaissent déjà
avant à la maison hqe risque été bons +
maintenant 1 h est ce qu est le moins
cher pour dire l'impact de la crise
économique sur sa vie louise à la prof
n'a pas voulu parler devant ses élèves
j'ai deux collègues qui font maintenant
femme de ménage en une heure et demie
elle gagne autant que moi en un mois
c'est comme ça les professeurs sont sous
payés mais en russie
ils sont toujours respectés c'est
pourquoi on leur offre des fleurs à
partir d'aujourd'hui dit la directrice
vous commencez le grand voyage vers le
monde des adultes
les états unis avaient justifié le
récent bombardement de lusine de
khartoum au soudan en affirmant que
cette usine
celle-ci fabriquer des composants
d'armes chimiques ils n'en sont plus
certains un responsable des services de
renseignement américains a déclaré
aujourd'hui ignorer si le composant
chimique était bien produit dans cette
usine où seulement à proposer ou bien
encore renverser le bombardement
américain du 20-août de khartoum avait
fait 17 morts une centaine de blessés et
300 disparus selon les autorités
soudanaises
la compagnie aérienne américaine
northwest airlines vient de procéder à
un licenciement massif de 27 mille cinq
cents personnes licenciées soit la
moitié de ses effectifs
les négociations entre la direction de
north west airlines et des pilotes
n'ayant pas abouti en france début du
mois de septembre marque la fin d'une
nouvelle période de travail pour ce que
l'on appelle les saisonniers
l'ancien ministre anicet le pors
rédigeant ce moment un rapport à la
demande du gouvernement sur les
conditions de travail des saisonniers
seraient entre 500 et 800 mille souvent
en situation précaire voici deux
histoires qui le démontrent reportage
sébastien guibert et nathalie gallet
l'hiver dernier à courchevel julien a
partagé son temps entre l'air pur des
montagnes et les odeurs grâce de cuisine
cinq mois intensifs commis dans un
restaurant fin avril
julien est rentré au pays golfe du
morbihan en bretagne
ici sur l'île aux moines c'est la
troisième année qu'il vient travailler à
deux pas de chez lui pour la saison
d'été cette fois l'hiver l'été deux
périodes que les saisonniers comme
julien consacre presque entièrement au
travail certains c'est steve à 9 heures
le matin ils vont à fond boulot le
service après ils vont se reposer parce
que bon et se sortir le soir ils
reprennent le boulot et après c'est fini
ça me nuit pour refaire la fête et ça
s'enchaîne comme ça et mais c'est vrai
qu'à un moment tu je suis plus gros
surtout content a pas de jours de congés
pendant cinq mois c'est pas évident ici
le patron et régulier julien prendra
bien ses congés et touchera son salaire
5600 francs nets plus une rallonge
consentis par le patron un patron
pourtant qui a vous demandez parfois ces
quatorze saisonniers davantage que les
43 heure légale hebdomadaire fixé dans
la profession c'est pour ça que j'ai bon
j'essaye de faire des horaires quand
même assez carré il ya une heure
d'arrivée une heure de départ on en
restauration est toujours un quart
d'heure et une demi heure de battement
sait jamais suivant le monde qui a c'est
vrai que pour le salaire qu'ils ont
ils sont toujours dessus un jour de
repos par semaine
horaires lourds contrats précaires bas
salaires les saisonniers n'ont pas la
vie facile beaucoup l'acceptent faute de
mieux ou pour partir quelques mois en
vacances à l'automne julien ira
certainement faire du surf au maroc ou
ailleurs
il n'a que 20 ans et le rythme du
saisonnier lui convient pour l'instant
mathieu lui travaille à capbreton à 25
ans il a déjà cinq années de saisonniers
derrière lui sa demi-journée de repos il
la passe et a dormi on ne peut pas avoir
un rythme normal de vie normale pendant
puisque pendant quatre mois on bosse on
ne fait que ça et après on passe du tout
de tout au rien en fait
donc c'est pas bon on est un mauvais
équilibre et puis bon même au bout de
cinq ans pense que j'ai fait le tour
aussi est bon ça ça suffit quoi beaucoup
de lassitude mais il est à l'argent
grâce aux pourboires
ils doublent quelques fois son salaire
de 6500 francs net ça reste pourtant
inférieure à ce qu'a pu connaître lirio
son responsable saisonniers depuis 20
ans on demande de payer les loyers mais
comme ils gagneraient à 1000 francs que
voulez vous pour se payer un loyer à
2500 francs comme dans la famille 3 nous
à l'époque on gagner le smic était qu un
3000 mais ont gagné 15 ou 18 dont
construit envoyé quoi le patron de son
côté assure qu'il ne peut guère amélioré
la situation de ces salariés
il faut un vrai que quand nous aide
parce que pour faire pour embaucher
aujourd'hui en restauration nous sommes
à 35 à 40% de masse salariale par
rapport à nos chiffres d'affaires
si les prochaines embauches se font sur
les mêmes bases nous ne pourrons pas
embaucher le gouvernement a commandé un
rapport pour la fin de l'année
alarmiste sur leur situation sociale le
rapport devrait proposer aux saisonniers
un statut particulier tentative de
rempart à leur fragilité
ce soir ce sont les dernières heures de
vacances je veux pas dire select sourire
avant la rentrée scolaire demain matin
pour les élèves des écoles primaires et
des collèges selon une enquête que
publie le journal non quotidiens quatre
élèves sur 5 se disent contents de
rentrer en classe mais ce passage du
statut de vacanciers à celui d'élèves ne
se fait pas toujours facilement les
rythmes biologiques sont évidemment
différent exemple avec ce petit garçon
qui entrent en cours élémentaire
première année le reportage et de benoît
thévenet et dominique bonnet fin de
vacances et dernière partie de pétanque
multicolores pour alexandre 7 ans et sa
petite soeur lucie âgée de quatre ans
alexandre est un petit garçon peu
contrariant il n'est pas inquiet pour sa
rentrée et entre vacances et écoles il
ne choisit pas
pourquoi toile et la france l'école les
bienvenus
les familles
il aime les deux mais alexandre ne s'est
pas encore aperçu des mauvaises
habitudes qu'il a triché sa grand-mère
bigorre il dort jamais avant 11h 11h30
parfois mai minuit c'était pas très
indiqué mais enfin voilà son rythme de
vie aux sables d'olonne quoi quand il
vient en vacances avec moi bref l'été la
vie d'alex change du tout au tout ils se
couchent turf et la grasse matinée
beaucoup d'activités physiques et
grignote toute la journée
résultat le jambon et les pommes de
terres restent dans l'assiette
les habitudes sont vaincus donc
on n'est plus dans des menus je dirais
traditionnels at elle vaut manger pour
respecter des horaires donc il a mangé
tout à l'heure sur la plage d'une glace
un croissant et puis bon c'est vrai qu'à
8 heures du dîner du soir
c'est trop tôt on commençait de nouveau
je dirais pas normal mais alexandre ne
perds pas l'nord deux heures plus tard
il engloutit une nouvelle glace ce soir
là il se couche à 23h presque
raisonnable
trois jours plus tard c'est la veille de
la rentrée et aujourd'hui tout le monde
au lit à 21h un changement d'habitude
pas facile à faire admettre du jour au
lendemain
c'est plus le le coucher qui posera
problème parce que bon lever la limite
l'enfance est un petit peu plus tôt
c'est aussi bien il a le temps de
prendre son petit déjeuner et de se
mettre en condition pour l'école donc
c'est essentiellement le soir qui posera
un peu plus de problèmes j'en ai même
reprend de l'année scolaire s'est
retrouvé une régularité de vignes et
quelques rituels pour aller dormir
lendemain tout le monde paraît en forme
mais ce n'est qu'une illusion
on peut comparer le changement de rythme
au retour des vacances avec le les
changements de rythme également quand
nous changeons under à l'automne et au
printemps selon son âge un enfant a
besoin de dormir 10 à 12 heures par nuit
un sommeil indispensable pour réactiver
les acquis de l'an dernier que deux mois
de vacances ont repoussé en partie au
fond de la mémoire
sport du tennis dès le premier tour
éliminatoire du tournoi de l'us open à
new york le français cédric pioline a
été éliminé en cinq sets par le suédois
jonas bjorkman demi finaliste l'an
dernier
qualification en revanche des français
jérôme golmard fabrice santoro ainsi que
d'arnaud di pascuale le français
champion du monde junior puis pascal
guimier me signale que bernard barrère
l'allemand a battu le tête de série le
tchèque corde à johnny hallyday au stade
de france pour trois spectacles
exceptionnels vendredi samedi et
dimanche johnny hallyday dont le
magazine team homme que j'ai ici
confesse qu'il n'aime pas les gens qui
vivent de manière étriquée
ce sont des gens sans folie il voit tout
en petits dit il et johnny hallyday de
faire le contraire puisque dans le stade
de france où l'équipe d'aimé jacquet fut
sacrée championne du monde
il se produira devant deux cent mille
personnes au total et pour arriver dans
ce stade il utilisera la voie des airs
avec l'autorisation la direction
générale de l'aviation civile du
consortium du stade de france il
habileté d'un pilote remarquable franck
arrestier johnny hallyday embarquera aux
côtés de michel drucker en hélicoptère
alors il ya très peu de temps avec
michel drucker et bien nous avons
enregistré c'est une exclusivité la
répétition de cette ouverture de
spectacle de johnny hallyday une
véritable première
c'est en effet cher claude sérillon une
grande première que les spectateurs du
stade de france vont vivre vendredi
samedi et dimanche soir entre 20h30 et
22h45 jeu ni ne fait pas les choses
comme tout le monde le lieu est magique
il est mythique c'est le stade des
champions du monde je n'étais que le
modeste artisan de cette arrivée
johnny ya quelques mois tu tenais
vraiment arriver par la voie des airs
maintenant qu'il peut plus reculer
comment du sang c'est une répétition
non ça va tout va bien ouais ouais ouais
tout va bien j'ai toujours aimé les
émotions fortes
donc je servais
les a
c'est parra
vainqueur
fais entrer dans tes spectacles ont été
à chaque fois très différentes il ya une
main il ya eu beaucoup j'ai toujours
essayé de
de soisy remet entre eux et puis mes
sorties c'est sont les conseillent
d'ailleurs quand j'étais môme de ce
qu'on m'avait du marais chevalier il m'a
dit ban il m'appelait le monde utilisait
boom soin de tes entrées soit sorti au
milieu et bien fait ton métier
cette préparation c'est quand même des
mois et au niveau des mois de
préparation pour trois jours et
finalement ça arrive très vite et puis
ça passe très vite
alors c'est vrai que c'est une double
concentration parce que c'est quand même
une épreuve d'arriver au dessus d'un
stade en hélico et après il faut chanter
pendant deux heures et demie oui même de
gérer même un peu plus longtemps que ses
ennemis mais bah oui bah écoute après ça
devient un plaisir
il est bien là
elle
voilà les images sont de christophe
airaud et merci à notre complice michel
drucker je vous conseille d'utiliser le
rer ce sera plus pratique comme pour les
matchs de foot pour se rendre au stade
de france et puis vous cirque envoyé
spécial évoquera très longuement johnny
hallyday le 17 septembre prochain
fin de cette édition je vous rappelle
deux informations nous avons développé
dans ce journal
l'opération de police menée dans 21 pays
dans le monde contre un réseau de
pédophiles utilisant internet
une centaine de personnes arrêtées des
dizaines de milliers de photos puis
charles millon exclu duo pdf parlement
dénonce le petit jeux d'appareil et
rappelle qu'il n'a pas été entendu par
ses anciens amis de l'udf dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinet nous
attend avec un temps maussade et puis
gérard klein dans l'instit le dernier
journal sera présenté par florence du
prat vers zéro heure vingt demain 7h50
yannick letranchant recevra pour les 4
vérités didier quillot qui le directeur
commercial france télécom mobile à
demain 20h bonsoir merci